hi i am susan quintanilla i am one of
the executive producers for selena the
series
hi i'm linda gonzalez i placed second
dania on salinas series
selena
i thought it'd be a good idea to
interview each other for
e.t it's so fun
so exciting is there anything
that you learned or were surprised to
learn about
me while preparing for this role
surprise
let me tell you i thought i knew
everything about you
i was such a big fan i saw your like
you know some facts online and i'm sure
i saw that you were left-handed when we
met
and you told me like i'm left-handed so
the kit is set up
right-handed and i am right-handed
naturally so i didn't think twice
about playing right-handed so you were
not only learning a new instrument
rewiring for that but then also rewiring
for your
from your dominant hand to your
non-dominant hand to play
and i was just like what like
that blew my mind it was hard enough for
me
you know why though right my because
that kit was originally
supposed to be for my cousin and that
because he was supposed to play and he
was right-handed so
yeah i i don't think a lot of people
knew back then i
definitely know now that the series is
out but yeah i
am uh left-handed and i do everything
left-handed
except for play the drums i play the
drums right handed
[Applause]
vegan performances what were your
favorite or least
favorite performance looks for selena
los dinos
my least favorite uh the cow print oh my
god
hands down the cow print outfit i go
back and i look at those i'm like
what were we thinking and i'm like and
then i tried to think about what was the
vibe back then
cow print was the vibe back then my
favorite
i would have to say was
um selena had we had done these purple
shimmer
type of uh jack like
outfits it was kind of like organza
purplish
iridescent type of vibe those were my
favorite and also
red black and white and everybody has
those three tones going on
yes like kind of like rocker cool
type of vibe yes that probably was
would would be on the top of my list for
my favorite
what was the name of the first song
that you learned how to play drums to
drum roll please
[Music]
really that was the first song i learned
how to play
and i felt so confident i felt
i felt like oh i could do anything now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it was wild to get to learn the drums i
had no experience whatsoever on them
before
i felt like i found myself and
rediscovered myself
through the drums do you have any i
don't know
life tips or like just this awareness of
what self-development
help could be found in playing music or
having music as a part of your life
early on like i didn't have that
confidence because of the fact that
girls didn't play drums and i was dead
set against playing so i didn't have
that confidence
as i started my drumming
this is going to sound crazy to you guys
but
it came after she passed like i can now
look
back because when you're in a way when
you're in it you don't realize what's
what you're really doing so to speak and
so when you step out of the box and
you know i really would like i would see
our live concerts you know and
and i'd be like hey you know wow like
okay
like i get it now looking back
at our live performances it it
it makes me want to dance it makes me
feel good knowing that i was able to do
that
was there any song that you discovered
that now during the filming has become
your like repeat song i checked my my
playlist
and to see what was the most played and
the most played was yo fuyakeya
[Music]
i especially loved
[Music]
[Music]
christian gabe myself the rest of the
band at that time we
loved playing that song the crew
everyone would be dancing to that
because it's just so funky
i saw the first season again you know
and i was like
wow they really like really dug in deep
into a lot of our older music
that we really started on that it hasn't
gotten a lot of light you know and if
those who view or wondering about it go
check it out it's actually a good jam
it really is great jam by silly nails so
if selena were performing right now what
would her evolution be like
would she be rock and roll which should
be r b
like what do you think i know that she
loved a little r
b she would have been more like beyonce
with a little bit
of sierra you know okay
like you know what i mean um
yeah for sure right i could totally say
beyonce that's for sure especially with
her time with mario boyz
and and the sounds that were coming out
the r b
influence i know you guys love janet
jackson as well yes i think she would
have been amazing at it i know it for a
fact oh i know it i know
if she would have been alive she would
have just recently turned you know 50
last month
mom and i were talking about it and we
were like hey do you remember that time
and she was like yeah when i'm about 50
years old
i'm still going to be performing and
then she turned around and she pushed
her stomach
out and she turned around like she was
singing and she goes i'm still going to
be wearing my bustiers and
i'm going to have a bonsai in my
leggings
and it just felt good to just kind of
reminisce about
those times where'd you get these
funeral next door don't worry about it
selena i don't think i've ever told you
this but they had narrowed it down to
about four different actresses
and of course you were one of them and i
remember
you know i was like okay okay okay when
i got to you know me i
literally felt you like
i felt like you were me whenever i saw
your audition tape i was like
oh yeah yeah we just need to we need to
plump her up a little bit but
you know and you're welcome and cut off
my hair oh girl
i know that must have been a lot for you
to be able to do that
complete transformation and i thank you
so much and you did a great job
you did a great great job but i hope it
was well worth it
of course her hair grows back
back weight can't wait can be lost or
added like
i'm playing a role of a lifetime getting
to play you and
getting to connect with you and it was
just such an honor to feel
my feminine divine through your
character
i had no problem with the first day they
cut my hair i was like take it
i gained weight changed my body and i
also
learned how to play the drums so i had
to do those
three physical things because the drums
are a
really physically demanding instrument
it was a very
physically demanding and and um
wonderful way to like challenge myself
as
an actor and artist it was so cool to
get this this roll of a lifetime this
character that's just so beautiful
suzette
so i'm seriously so thankful for you
[Music]
why is selena such an icon and so
important to latinx and mainstream
culture
tell me suzette let's just start off
first with
that amazing personality that she had
and that the uh
that vibe that she would just give off
of
like being okay with who she was and
make fun of herself and
had this extremely amazing smile that
would just bring you in and make you
feel at ease and
felt comfortable around or if you were
watching her
um let's talk about that amazing voice
where she could
um do so many different genres of music
and and
still capture you with a cumbia or a
romantic
song clearly physically selena had such
a beautiful body and she was curvaceous
and much like all of like most latinos
were built like that you know we are
blessed what was that one moment that
you felt that you were represented
as a latina like on in a role or like in
a tv
series the first time i felt seen on
screen
felt represented on screen drumroll
please
it was selena the movie it was selena
the movie it was
j-lo it was it was jackie guerra playing
you
it was um all the characters there that
played this family
it's just a bustier it's a cool thing
it's a bra
it's a brawl with little sprinkly things
on it to have the movie then
and now have the series where we're
continuing that representation
um so people can see scene and all these
um family and band dynamics and i'm now
suzette with in this series and it was i
have chills
it was it was a really beautiful
blessing so how
old were you whenever you saw the selena
movie i had to be in grade school at the
time like
probably 10 8 the fact that we were
seeing
ourselves on screen in this community we
went we all went to support and it was
just so cool to see
all these latinos of different
backgrounds going to see the movie
in the 90s and and now i we have it in
our homes
watching it on netflix people enjoying
anything
friends i didn't know that this is the
first time i'm hearing this so this is
so cool
if you could single out one particular
moment
in the series for you to get it like
straight up
on point the opening number of como la
flor life
because i had learned drumming just two
and a half months before that and i had
to look like i had been playing for so
long
it meant a lot to me because i wanted to
play with the spirit
of the sibling bond and relationship the
camera would pants a christian looking
at me
uh christian looking at a b me and a b
look gabe looking at each other
so it mattered to me that i was able to
um
give so much heart and soul into that
performance
hid everything right because as you know
there's a lot of pills in that in that
rendition
and i had to act on top of it so it was
a very very tall order for actor turned
musician
specifically drummer to make sure that i
honored your
legacy and your sibling love i have one
other
question i want to ask you how difficult
was it for you
to um experience the
latter part of the series you know the
loss of losing selena he has a
really really good question love um yeah
it was uh difficult to
um gear up for for these scenes that
were
heavier because you just obviously can't
imagine this kind of thing could ever
happen
i noticed i would want to be in this
mode more bubbly more fun more happy
smiling but i my spirit just was tapped
in
to what i had to do at my nine to five
on set and so
i was susceptible to to being emotional
that time i was susceptible to being
heavier
with friends and family and i just love
everyone for supporting me if they knew
that i was going through it and i'm
happy to
say that i i i'm back to smiling yeah
i remember you and i spoke about that
it's such a
difficult moment
in time you know because you know a lot
of people like i can't believe y'all put
that in
you know that you know that the person
who took her life that was in there
and it's like well she has to be in
there because this is this is life
this is what it's like yeah this is what
happened and so it would
not be true to you know what what was
going on
but i just wanted to you know tell you
and give you much love
it's not just about learning the drums
or
being a sibling or you know we talk a
lot about that but it was also the other
part that comes along with it a lot of
acting and a lot of
deeping deep digging deep and bringing
that
part of who you are
how did you and selena navigate beauty
standards back then like what did you
all live by back then
that's a good question it was more of a
location
whatever comes whatever however and uh
back then
trust me celine and i really just
vibe whatever we really wanted to do
like right
you know i read your article by the way
and uh one of your articles that you
actually
wrote and you talk about body positivity
and even though my sister was
physically on point um that i would have
some form of insecurity because i've
always been
a plus size girl you know uh aka fluffy
and um yeah i don't
i really have never felt insecure like i
really haven't if any insecurity was me
performing as a female drummer
and not really knowing my craft but as
far as me personally i
never felt any less i have definitely
i fluctuate in weight just like everyone
um that's i i think tries to lose weight
to feel
more comfortable of who i am how i feel
uh right now i'm carrying my covered
weight and like i like to say and
i'm fine with that you know and and i
just feel comfortable with who i am
and i think that that needs to be thrown
out there more
of uh to the younger generation that
what we see
online is not it's not really what you
really see
normie you had opened up about
redefining beauty
and how you felt how you feel now with
shorter hair and putting on a little bit
of weight
like how has that been dealing with
the fan base that comes along with
selena it has been
it has been wonderful it has been a
journey for sure but i'm so thankful
because
because of you how great you look and
dynamic within the 10 years i've been
working they've known that the
long-haired noisy
um that now they have this version and
that they're excited that really was
a um a breakthrough for me to have your
character
after being in la for 10 years
redefining my standards of beauty so i
i'm telling you i really do appreciate
that i had you as like a pillar of
strength
do you have a memory that the fans don't
know about you and selena
i'll leave you with something funny she
would uh
we we shared a room together for many
many years and
she would always get me annoying me by
uh
scratching my back so i can relax you
know so you scratch my back basically i
said you're like like a little monkey
and and she would like you go you but
you do me first i'm like you better not
fall asleep
i'll sleep i'm gonna be real mad and she
would always fall asleep on me annoying
me
like could you not or i would like
massage your back a little bit like okay
my turn if you'd be asleep i'm like i
know you're not
asleep those are the moments that i miss
the most
[Music]
you